WOMEN.
THE IMAGES YOU'RE ABOUT TO SEE
ARE FRIGHTENING.
AE
A TODDLER DRESSED JIHAD IS
ENCOURAGED TO BEHEAD HIS TEDDY
BEAR.
THE DISTURBING SCENE
RAQQAH SYRIA.
BOYS AS YOUNG AS 5 YEAR OLDS OLD
IN AN ISIS CAMP TRAINING FOR THE
GROUP'S SIGNATURE EXECUTIONS.
>> IN THIS CAMP THEY TRY TO
TEACH THEM THE IDEOLOGY OF ISIS.
THEY SENT THEM TO BOMB THEMSELF,
THEY USE THEM TO CARRY WE
WEAPONS, MEDICAL STUFF IN THE
CLASHES.
>> Reporter: THEY ARE RAISING
JIHADS FROM A SMALL AGE.
>> YES.
>> Reporter: VIDEOS USED BY
MEDIA OUTLETS LIKE CNN ARE THE
ONLY WAY TO SAY WHAT LIFE IS
LIFE UNDER EXTREMIST RULE.
ISIS BANNED JOURNALIST,
REPLACING THEM WITH SLICK
PROPAGANDA GLAMORIZING LIFE IN
THE STATE.
A DOZEN ACTIVIST ARE PULLING
BACK THE CURTAIN OF ISIS RULE IN
THEIR CITY, ONCE AMONG SYRIA'S
MOST LIBERAL.
THEY CALL THEMSELVES RAQQAH IS
BEING SLAUGHTERED SILENTLY.
>> ISIS STARTED TO EXECUTE AND
HUMORIZE IN RAQQAH AND NO ONE
DID ANYTHING FOR THE CITY, NO
ONE EVERY HEARD ABOUT IT.
SO WE DID OUR CAMPAIGN TRYING TO
PUT THE ATTENTION ON OUR CITY TO
MAYBE SOMEONE WILL DO SOMETHING
TO THE CITY.
>> Reporter: THE PHOTOS AND
IMAGES THEY SMUGGLE OUT, A
LIFELINE TO THE OUTSIDE WORLD.
>> YOU CAN SAY NO LIFE IN
RAQQAH.
YOU CAN'T DO ANYTHING.
NO SCHOOLS, NO UNIVERSITIES,
NOTHING TO DO AND EVERYTHING IS
EXPENSIVE.
>> Reporter: IT SOUNDS LIKE
HELL.
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: ONE WOMAN SNUCK A
CAMERA UNDER HER VAIL RISKING
HER LIFE TO FILM THIS VIDEO
DEPICTING ISIS BRUTAL TREATMENT
OF WOMEN.
>> THEY CAN'T GO OUTSIDE ALONE.
IF SHE WANT TO GO OUTSIDE, SHE
SHOULD GO WITH A HUSBAND,
FATHER, BROTHER, OR WHATEVER AND
SHE SHOULD -- AND SHE SHOULD
COVER ALL HERSELF.
THE WOMAN IN RAQQAH OR IN ISIS
AREAS ARE NOTHING, JUST THEY USE
THEM ONLY TO DO SEX, TO BUY AND
SELL THE YEZIDI GIRLS.
>> Reporter: THEY ARE MAKING
THEM PROSTITUTES?
>> YES.
>> Reporter: THEY WERE COVERING
CLASHES WHEN ISIS STORMED HIS
HOUSE.
HE MANAGED TO ESCAPE THE COUNTRY
AND NOW MANAGES THE GROUP'S
SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> ISIS ARRESTED ONE OF OUR
BORDERS.
THEY TOOK HIS LAPTOP AND FOUND
OUR CAMPAIGN LOGO AND AFTER
THREE WEEKS, THEY EXECUTED HIM
IN A PUBLIC SQUARE.
>> Reporter: LAST MONTH ONE OF
THEIR MEMBERS WORKING IN TURKEY
WAS BEHEADED.
WHY ARE YOU JOURNALIST SHOWING
WHAT IS GOING ON IN RAQQAH
INSTEAD OF BEING FIGHTERS
KILLING ISIS FIGHTERS?
>> IF YOU WILL DEFEAT ISIS AND
YOU DIDN'T DEFEAT THE IDEOLOGY
OF